thank you
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story an industry accused of
pumping up prices as the government
tells garages they'll be forced to be
more open over fuel
the near billion pound bill paid by
drivers after supermarkets decided says
the regulator to prioritize their profit
margins
also tonight it's war on the streets of
France the Stark language from one
police officer as a mayor whose family
nearly died says democracy is being
attacked
the battle inside a West Bank town as
Israel's military launches its biggest
operation there in nearly two decades
feeling the heat the impact of a
record-breaking month for temperature
and low rainfall on the UK
why the Russians are coming to Wimbledon
at least the fans welcoming back players
after the lifting of the ban over the
wall
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening our biggest
supermarkets could have put the brakes
on higher fuel prices driven by the war
in Ukraine the competition regulator
reported today instead they built their
profit margins increasing the cost of
filling up the average car by around
three pounds a time well last year
drivers paid on average some
eye-watering sums for fuel just over 165
Pence a liter for unleaded petrol and
just over 178 Pence for diesel but
according to the competition and markets
Authority prices should have been six
pence a liter lower if the big four
supermarkets hadn't been protecting
their profit margins as a result
Britain's motorists paid a total of 900
million pounds more for their fuel and
while the CMA says there's no evidence
the supermarkets had been operating a
cartel it does say there should be a new
legally mandated system requiring fuel
providers to publish live data on fuel
charges a business correspondent Paul
Kelso has this report
well there's Sainsbury's won 39 a liter
for petrol 143 for diesel wonder if
that'll be the cheapest we can find
in Watford like pretty much every town
in Britain you have to work quite hard
to find the cheapest tank of fuel and
look at that
10p more expensive that's because
supermarkets aren't working as hard to
keep prices down according to the
competition Watchdog which says profit
margins have grown
Asda in particular historically has been
the cheapest of the supermarkets back in
2022 they took a decision to increase
their internal margin targets actually
trouble their margin targets we saw a
similar move by Morrisons to double
their targets now in a market where
competition is working well you'd expect
other retailers of the supermarkets of a
few retailers to respond competitively
to seek to win market share we haven't
seen that happen at all
more than half of the price of a liter
of petrol is made up of fuel Duty and
vat with another quarter or so set by
the oil price after refining costs and
exchange rates the retail spread
including costs and profit accounts for
11 percent
but the CMA found that while the pump
price here in red has fallen from its
peak of almost two pounds the Gap with
the wholesale price in Black has grown
A1 taxis run 150 vehicles in and around
Watford offering fixed prices
says the lack of competition for fuel is
hitting drivers and customers the
supermarkets you know there's not been
much difference in price between them
and your you know your shelves and your
BPS you know with that client base being
the working class how do we reflect that
in the prices uh without upsetting them
and losing our customers the
supermarkets say they are committed to
competition but government will now
force them to share information
so it turns out Asda is the cheapest
just from Sainsbury's but it's taken
quite a lot of driving to work that out
the recommendation is that it's made
easier for drivers by retailers
providing real-time live price
information that could be used on a
phone it could be on your Sat Nav make
it easier for you to find the best deal
that will increase competition locally
hopefully bring down prices
motoring groups say the move is overdue
we see today very much as a landmark for
drivers we hope that it's going to lead
to fairer pricing on the fork or going
forwards uh the presence of a Fuel
Finder to allow people to find the
cheapest fuel near them near them is a
good move
wider profit margins at Asda and
Morrisons have come after both were
subject to debt-fueled takeovers with
financing costs to meet on top of
inflation drivers may have to wait for a
better deal
well Paula SIM buckinghamshire for us
tonight and pull the government moving
very quickly to back up this report
today but in it evidence that there are
more challenges for drivers to come
yes this report has been unequivocal
consumers have been getting a bad deal
at the pumps for three reasons the
invasion of Ukraine has pushed up the
oil price that's brought food inflation
which has put supermarkets under
pressure and the traditional Cost Cutter
Asda under new ownership has decided to
start increasing its margins and frankly
it has suited its Rivals Tesco and
Sainsbury's to follow suit so it's very
easy for the government to back this
report and its main recommendation fuel
prices matter to millions of Voters and
that main recommendation of an app to
help share prices it's not going to cost
the taxpayer anything and it might Focus
attention more on the retailers than the
ATP or so of tax that goes to the
treasury from every liter much harder to
see is how those market conditions that
now Prevail are going to change we
should expect prices to remain high in
the medium term and the CMA has said
things might be getting worse the move
to electric vehicles which is going to
be compulsory for new cars from 2030
under the government's new legislation
is likely to make the fuel Market even
less competitive for those who can't
afford to make the switch
Paul Kelso thank you
hundreds of Israeli troops were deployed
today in a West Bank Town in one of the
biggest operations in two decades at
least eight Palestinians were killed in
Janine the U.N Secretary General was
said to be deeply concerned with the
Israeli Army launched its attack early
this morning deploying a force described
as Brigade size which could be as many
as 2 000 soldiers in the north of the
occupied West Bank the refugee camp in
Janine is around 90 miles from Jerusalem
and home to around 14 000 Palestinians
our Middle East correspondent Aleister
bunkel reports
the first is ready drone strikes hit
Janine shortly after one o'clock on
Monday morning
the Israeli military says they hit a
joint Operation Center which was a
meeting and Sheltering point for wanted
terrorists
by Dawn army vehicles were on the
streets of the City closing off roads
and shutting Janine down
there are around a thousand Israeli
soldiers involved in the operation
our forces entered into the terrorists
nests they eliminate terrorists they
arrest wanted persons they destroy
headquarters and seize many weapons they
destroy laboratories on an almost
industrial scale Laboratories from which
they created explosives intended for the
slaughter and murder of Israeli
civilians
heavily armed bulldozers were sent in to
counter the threat from roadside bombs
and clear the streets tearing up the
tarmac to make it harder for militants
to move around
and Israeli soldiers have not holed
through walls to make sniper positions
residence in Janine were sent text
messages
urging them to stay indoors at the same
time calls were made from the mosques
encouraging people to fight and defend
the city
ambulances rushed to help the wounded
and collect the dead I can't sleep
because all this noise and all this
bombs around us I can't move because the
Israel army they are occupied all the
streets they don't allowed for us to
move at the same time it's really it's
it's dangerous to move Israel Target any
person he just moved so we can't be in
there in their face or we can't be in
the live by normal way understand our
home as curfew as I mean we can't move
we can't move it's not allowed for us to
move the operation was approved after a
series of events in recent weeks four
Israelis were shot dead at a petrol
station in the West Bank
a few days ago this video was released
by Palestinian militants attempting to
fire homemade Rockets into Israel
the message from the IDF is that this is
a limited operation to restore
deterrents and they don't expect it to
widen Beyond Janine into other parts of
the West Bank
they won't put a time limit on it most
people expect it to last a few days
alistabunga Sky News in Jerusalem
people talk about riots but for those on
the front line it's War a senior police
officer near Paris told us today he was
speaking as the mayor whose family
escaped after a car on fire rammed their
home at the weekend called those
attackers assassins our Europe
correspondent Adam Parsons reports from
Larry Larose a suburb to the south of
Paris
[Music]
their singing for this man their mayor
but also for their town and for their
country the French national anthem is
all about pride and resistance and on
the streets of we found both
they were cheering the mayor and whose
family had to flee their home when it
was attacked using a burning car and
this March was all about Defiance in the
face of violence
overseeing it the town's police chief
Eric Vern for him it's been an
exhausting week and when we spoke he was
remarkably strident
people talk about riots but for those of
us who have to deal with it it's War
those people who stand in front of us
they're there to kill us they have
Molotov cocktails they have cobbles they
come within three meters in front of us
they throw enormous slabs of pavement at
us they try to kill us not to play with
us they're there to kill us
the mayor looked haunted he is a symbol
of this fractured tired country
the mayor of this unassuming Paris
suburb has suddenly been crossed into
the national Spotlight as a sort of
totem of the resistance and irritation
of the French people and at the end
words for the people who try to burn
down his house
we have seen the true face of the
rioters so that of Assassins
they wanted to murder my wife and our
two young children in their sleep and
burn them alive while trying to burn
down our house
the greatest act of Bravery that Night
performed by a mother in saving our
little boy from the flames and our
little girl the Republic is also her
arrests in France has fallen there's
optimism the violence is coming to an
end but it will leave a legacy of
weariness and anger
I came today because I've had it up to
here it's too much we need it to stop we
need to show the whole world that we are
tired it needs to end
jean-bron like his Nation carries the
scars of trauma and violence and they
share the challenge of how to heal Adam
Parson Sky News lails
[Applause]
and we'll have more on the French
protests a little later in the program
one of the men who says he was sexually
assaulted by Kevin Spacey said he'd
threatened to knock him out one of the
times he touched him the Oscar winning
actor behaved like he could groom his
alleged victim London caught her today
her arts and entertainment correspondent
Katie Spencer was there and warning her
report contains flash photography
what Millions have seen Kevin Spacey
star on screen and Stage the first
alleged victim to give evidence in the
trial against him said watching the
a-lister ACT makes him feel sick Spacey
once again arriving hours before he was
needed in court and described as being
slippery snakey a predator
the alleged victim a driver who
encountered the Oscar winner on a number
of occasions in the early 2000s said
Spacey would always sit in the front of
the car and was very touchy-feely
recalling 12 occasions when he started
to grab meat and grape me there were
incidents where he'd grab my hand and
put it on him then he'd laugh it off
every time I said no he'd leave it a
month and start again
dropping him off at a Showbiz party once
he said Spacey had had a couple of
drinks and was quite fired up he grabbed
me so hard I almost came off the road I
pulled over and said don't do it again
or I'll knock you out he laughed and
said it was a turn on he said come on
let's go to the party don't be silly the
jury hearing how the man told police I
used to call him a weirdo he used to
laugh about it he wasn't embarrassed a
couple of weeks would go by and he'd do
it again
the alleged victim said it left him
feeling so anxious that he struggled
sleeping and felt that he couldn't
confide in anyone because they wouldn't
understand and when lawyers for Spacey
put it to him that perhaps he might have
struggled to process what they described
as his complicated and confusing
feelings about that time he said no
nothing happened between us he was
assaulting me
Spacey vehemently denies the allegations
made against him by four men his lawyers
previously saying that the actor Will in
his evidence explain how many of the
incidents have been reimagined with a
Sinister spin Katie Spencer Sky News
an investigation has found that
partygate investigator Sue gray broke
Civil Service rules as a result of the
Undeclared contact between her and the
labor party ahead of her appointment is
kirst Armor's Chief of Staff the former
senior civil servant was cleared to
start the job in September by the
Parliamentary anti-corruption Watchdog
but a separate cabinet Office inquiry
has found her in breach of the civil
service code due to her contact with the
labor leader
a man from Kettering has been jailed for
life for murdering his wife and two
young children
strangled his partner Andrew isoc and
their six-year-old son Jiva and
four-year-old daughter janvi last
December
rail passengers are facing six days of
disruption because of an overtime ban by
the train drivers Union asleff to pay
dispute affects 16 rail companies across
England the Union's boss told Sky News
his members would take action for two
decades if necessary
we're going to keep taking action until
someone listens to us
like you're whistling in the wind well
we have to whistle in the wind for five
years ten years 20 years to get somebody
to the table this will be resolved at
some point and somebody will talk to us
properly at some point and the fact that
we're willing look we've just had to
refresh all our mandates once more under
the Tory legislation for our industrial
action they've come back higher than if
they had before been in strike now for
14 months and our people still are
sending back the consists of 95 fraction
short strike and strike action that
tells your strength of feeling about the
people I represent this isn't mcwhelan
saying we want to go on strike this the
members of ash left saying they want a
fair deal
the summer of 1976 has gone down in now
Misty memory as a record breaker for the
heat of that summer at least in June was
surpassed this year for the first time
it was on average 15.8 degrees in the UK
across last month nearly a degree warmer
than the previous record and it's had a
hard impact on the environment as our
climate change and energy correspondent
Hannah Thomas Peter reports
a grim task for John Ellis from the
canal and River trust removing dead fish
from the Grand Union Canal near solihull
the oxygen pumps installed here weren't
enough to save them it's just one
incident of dozens across the country
over the past few weeks and evidence of
the impact of temperatures that the Met
Office has confirmed delivered the UK's
hottest June on record it's been an
unprecedented month what we're seeing is
dissolved oxygen levels in the water
that are so low that they can't support
fish life
and we think issues almost certainly
caused by the ever increasing
temperatures that we're seeing it's
damaging our Wildlife because not only
the fish themselves but the the birds
that and mammals that rely on fish your
herons your Kingfishers your grebs and
your otters will all suffer if we don't
have healthy fish populations in our
waterways Met Office data shows that
June temperatures have increased over
the decades this Jagged line shows June
extremes here are the previous high
points in 1940 1976 and now of course
2023 but this dotted line shows the
trend in average temperatures for the
months and over the last 40 years in
particular you can see it's been going
up it reflects a more General Trend all
10 of the UK's warmest years on record
happened in the last two decades and
2022 was the hottest of them all with
the average year-round temperature above
10 degrees be Celsius for the first time
ever
scientists warn that these conditions
Bear the Fingerprints of climate change
in the atmosphere and in the global
weather patterns we have natural
variability so there's a natural
phenomena that always occurs year on
year
what's different is the background state
of the warming climate that in some
senses give that turbo boost to that
natural variability
the Ripple effects of a hot start to
Summer have been widespread from new
hose pipe bands in Kent and Sussex
to this a few weeks ago in the Scottish
Highlands dry vegetation fueling
wildfire
hotter drier summers in the UK Pleasant
for many but also a sign of how our
world is changing Hannah Thomas Peter
Sky News
now we've watched scenes of violence
condemned across France and Beyond over
recent nights but one of the rioters
involved as tall Sky News that people
would be back out again if necessary he
said those writing had been fighting the
Injustice of French society he was
speaking to our correspondent Tom
Parmenter
who was shot dead by the police and how
do
right are you okay yes for him it was an
easy decision to go out and join the
rioting
the death of Neil I was revolted it was
a an injustice we were our group and the
group effect with the afraia adrenaline
to the uh Euphoria before yeah and
adrenaline to be in front of cops it was
to attack the symbol of the states
he was in Dante last Wednesday as
lawlessness took hold
the next night he was in obervillier as
this Northern suburb of Paris burned
if
um if there is a not police not another
police abuse I will not
stay in my room and just see the Medias
and you'll go out again yes
if the number of police of policemen and
the violence of policemen rights the
violence of us will act too open come up
come up yes
as we spoke on this quiet side street
sort of military Patrol turned up
they slowed right down but did move on
and with the death of now this is the
the proof of we need to um to film
control or every time the police speak
with young people we saw that in England
with but the cops have the body cameras
the project camera yes I think it's a
very good idea
and that would
make you more confident to deal with the
police yes yes but if you have you
achieved anything do you think
um we don't know it will be um we know
we will know that when the policeman
will be judged there are a lot of fights
to do to have Justice in this country I
think he would do it again there are
thousands like him
the divisions at the heart of all this
seem as deep as they've ever been
Tom Parmenter Sky News Paris
one set of sporting visitors Australia's
ashes team may not be the most welcome
in this country right now after the
controversy in yesterday's Cricket test
the treatment of Russian players at
Wimbledon last year there was positively
Siberian in comparison with them banned
over the war in Ukraine that has now
changed and at least one of their number
was warmly welcomed by fans as the
tournament began as our Sports
correspondent Rob Harris reports
back from being banished Andre rublev
and magnet for selfie Seekers on day one
of Wimbledon
blanket ban on Russians has been lifted
this year but this anti-war player has
to compete as a neutral as do all
players from Russia and Belarus as the
war on Ukraine continues
although we've made the decision to
admit those athletes this year that
doesn't change our position on the war
in Ukraine we completely condemn
Russia's illegal invasion
but the threat of further tennis
sanctions made maintaining the band
difficult after Wimbledon was stripped
of ranking points last year returning to
compete here required Russian and Bella
Russian players to sign declaration
saying they would show no support for
the war in Ukraine they can also receive
no funding from Russia or Belarus
rublev was in a rush on his return
beating Australia's Max Purcell in
straight sets as the first Russian into
the second round
but still disappointed over his enforced
year away I think we could find the
solution if we really want to help or to
do what is better for for tennis and for
for the people I think obviously there
was better options just not just to bend
as well there was home Joy with Jody
Burridge into the second round for the
first time I had so many people there
today
um but you know I know it's all support
I know they're there and want the best
for me
um and on days like today when you get a
win and a win at Wimbledon my first win
it's such a big win for me
um it's so nice to have people around
you so I'm so happy that they were here
to support
Liam Brody is also through
but Harriet darts Wimbledon ended
prematurely
much of the action was missed by these
fans who arrived before 7am and queued
for more than eight hours before getting
in
Security checks have been enhanced with
fears this could be the next just stop
oil power to protest Target the all
England Club is hoping for a respectful
crowd with no disruption with Andy
Murray beginning his bid for a third
Title Here on Tuesday Rob Harris Sky
News Wimbledon
including this story on the on the page
of the eye which says 67 of people want
a cap on Supermarket prices to help with
the cost of living well tonight we're
joined by pipakura political editor of
the guardian and Harry Cole political
editor of the Sun
[Music]
thank you
women's lives don't matter
women's lives are not valued here they
are running because we have an internal
work they're running to be safe do you
think you'll ever be able to stop the
violence against women the most striking
thing is this exceptions that's being
absolutely horrific is going to happen
to them
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hmm
well this is going to use in just a
moment the Press preview a first look at
what is on the front pages first a
reminder of our top stories this evening
an investigation by the competition
regulator has found that drivers paid
six pence per liter extra for fuel as a
result of supermarkets increasing their
margins last year
at least eight Palestinians have been
killed and 50 injured after Israel
launched airstrikes targeting the West
Bank City of Janine
and hundreds have taken part in peace
marches across France after six days of
violence in the country
[Music]
well hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with peppercara
political editor of the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor of the sun
great to see both of you
before we hear from them the front pages
let's kick off shall we with
the telegraph on the day supermarkets
are in the firing line over fuel prices
the telegraph has the headline motorists
used as fuel Cash Cow by Grocers the eye
has carried out a poll which reveals
that 67 percent of people also want a
cap on Supermarket prices generally to
help them cope with the soaring cost of
living news that last month was
officially the hottest June on record is
the top story for the Metro the headline
flaming June proposed new curbs on
immigration numbers lead the express
which says the proposals have been
blocked by the treasury a move which has
split the conservative party
papakura has tonight's lead story in the
guardian about Labor plans to improve
Nursery education for the underfores the
financial times says Bank Chiefs have
been called in by the financial
regulator to explain why saving rates
are lagging so far behind the rising
cost of mortgages but the Daily Mail
says banks are also facing investigation
over closing the accounts of people who
Express controversial views and the
Daily Star returns to its favorite
source of stories scientific buffins who
say that people's brains are shrinking
because of eating a bad diet while
Harry's paper the sun focuses on the
marital ups and downs of emmerdale's Amy
nuttal and her actor husband Andrew
buckin had you pronounce his name
buccane
no everyone's looking at me
anyway reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages
Optimus newspapers while you watch us so
let's uh get the thoughts of Pippa and
Harry and that theme really about
Supermarket prices fuel prices
um and indeed the idea of savings rates
lagging uh kicking off their Pippa with
the eye this idea of a supermarket price
cab which I thought had been ruled out
by the government it seems tempting to
Consumers but presumably it would have
knock-on impact for Farmers for example
wouldn't it
yeah I mean this is a policy which
actually hasn't been used since the
1970s
um but it was briefly considered last
month when food inflation looked like it
was stubbornly staying High
um it's 18.4 uh at the moment but
earlier this year reached a 45-year high
of 19.1 which is you know a massive
figure and one which we all feel when we
go to the supermarkets and fill up our
uh fill up our trolleys um and you know
even the most basic Goods milk eggs
bread things like that I've soared have
soared in in price
um and the story on the eye is is
actually based on a poll which finds
that 60 67 sorry of the public back
price controls
um you know caps on some of those Basics
Goods I mentioned like eggs and and
bread and so on
um and uh just 13 opposed the idea but
as you rightly say even though it was
briefly considered last month within
Whitehall number 10 in the treasury
ultimately rejected the idea obviously
they wouldn't feel that they wanted to
interfere in the markets and as you
rightly say there could be knock-on
effects
um but they have worn supermarkets both
the treasury number 10 and the bank of
England against using inflation to
rebuild profit margins which have been
hammered for a variety of reasons
including energy cost soaring post
Ukraine and of course the pandemic so
um I think the pressure that households
are feeling means that this this subject
isn't going to go away the inflation
remains High crucially Core inflation
and food price inflation and as long as
the public continues to feel the pain
the government is going to have it at
the top of this inbox and how it's going
to drive down inflation yes and I
thought that supermarkets or their their
official bodies suggest that actually
supermarkets run very low profit margins
you know it's a quantity business that's
where they get any profit from
um so is it a fair accusation against
them do you think because we're going to
come on to the fuel pump priced in a
moment in city am but just in terms of
grocery is it something the government
is very concerned about Harry
yeah I think it is and you can see the
the difference in certain prices of
certain foods some sort of some brands
are much more expensive than others for
everyone is essentially the same product
so there is a suspicion that perhaps
actually there is a bit of grams I think
they call it greed flation where under
the cover of soaring prices
um some products are kept artificially
High to go up at the same rate as other
products that are you know perhaps
oil-based products that are suffering
from the war in Ukraine
um where actually you know the
production cost of those products aren't
as expensive as some things that are
going up but they put the prices up
anyway now the supermarkets say heaven
forbid how dare you suggest we do such a
thing but um there is a lingering
suspicion just on that poll though I
think that 67 is quite um quite a
thumping uh quite a thumping number
often in that case as though you've got
to look at how the question was asked I
don't suspect that that the question was
would you like to see price caps in
supermarkets even though that would
automatically lead to less choice and
automatically lead to property shortages
because everywhere price caps are tried
that is the inevitable result yes indeed
and I know Farmers for example don't
think they get a fair price for milk for
example so there is a knock-on impact
and I suppose the supermarkets would say
that every price goes up because
transport costs go up and you know
that's the difficulty
um so what about the findings that we've
had reported in cityam you know and by
ourselves today that actually there was
a bit of inflation in the price of
petrol and Diesel over the last year
which has cost you know nearly
um uh you know 6p per liter three pounds
per time we visit a petrol station
effectively pepper
yeah I mean this is the results of a
year-long uh inquiry by the competition
and markets Authority which have looked
at the competition Watchdog which has
looked at what's going on on petrol Four
Courts where obviously we've seen prices
going up quite substantially and they're
suggesting that um petrol uh would have
might have been six pence a liter or
cheaper had wholesalers passed on and
retailers passed on uh the wholesale
savings and I think it's even more I
can't remember the exact figure I heard
earlier it was about 13p or something
like that for um for diesel but anyway
it's a it was a larger increase and the
super super market fuel margins these
are between 2019 and 2022 and City am
says 900 million pounds almost a billion
of a siphon debt of customers profits in
total so there's various things that are
going to happen
um the government says it's going to
legislate to guarantee more transparency
in the market in a bit down to price to
drive down prices over time
um and the CMA is calling for a plan to
help drivers get fairer prices including
a new fuel monitoring body to hold the
industry to account City am says that
that could also be backed up with
legislation as well to make fewer
retailers provide up-to-date up-to-date
pricing individually Absolute Data on
pricing I mean this all comes back to
the same thing is that consumers are
really feeling the pinch on top of all
the other cost of living pressures
they're feeling it at the supermarkets
they're feeling it at the petrol for
courts and the authorities the
governments and the various arms length
bodies are going to have to act to try
and ease some of that pressure and on a
slightly different but kind of connected
story and the financial times reporting
that the financial Watchdog is summoning
bank chief Executives to address
concerns that saving rates are lagging
behind the surging cost of mortgages
um to as ever thus I think probably
um but again this has also been a
concern of of people isn't it that you
know the banks gain while punishing
others effectively
yeah it just feels wherever we are
across the land there's an overstuffed
regulator that you know has all these
hundreds of peoples working for it but
doesn't it seem to be sort of acting
after the horse is bolted and only
really seem to to be acting now after
sort of public pressure whether that's
off what and off Gem and the water
regulator but dare I say often while on
television but I won't but it just seems
you know the FCA now playing catch up on
savings and the sun has been calling for
a pump watch there's this regulator for
Supermarket prices for months and months
and months years in fact as long as I
can remember we've been saying look
supermarkets are ripping people off and
the big four have finally been named and
shamed but it's taken years to get to
this point and that's absurd and
especially you know it shouldn't have
taken that massive soaring of petrol
prices last uh last year in the wake of
the invasion of Ukraine
um to get to this point you know
government being asleep at the wheel for
this for for more than a decade now and
you it's just saying you know what are
all these people doing what you know
what are what are these Regulators
stuffed over staff the people when you
know they seem to be failing on on every
account I'm going to stay with you if
it's all right um because it's uh inside
the Sun um Harry uh which is um rishi's
Summit on tackling the ecotoffs tell us
more
yeah so Wednesday
um Wednesday I think morning he's going
to be meeting with the cops he's going
to be bringing in sporting bodies the
big organizers bought the football uh
the football managing bodies
um to basically say look you've got to
sort this out we've got a new football
season starting we've got two weeks of
Wimbledon we've got three more test
matches we've got the British Grand Prix
um sort this out you know Johnny
birthday Managed IT the Prime Minister
makes the point in an op-ed in the sun
tomorrow you know you've got the laws
you've got the powers we've given you
those Powers now start using them so a
bit of a sort of banging their heads
together I think coming because the
point the prime ministers make is that
you know these protests are happening in
every other country around the world but
it's only us that seem to be putting up
with it so so frequently and allowing a
couple of you know sort of Eco swampy
trustiferian types to ruin days out for
everyone else so um we I believe it when
they see it when I see it actually
happen but um again once again it does
feel like the horse is somewhat bolted
the stable uh and the door is flapping
open and uh and the prime minister's
already now really is uh beginning to
try to shut it yes and and you know
controversy uh rages about the efficacy
of these protests Pippa but also about
the police Powers as well which were
themselves controversial
yes and of course
um the police have uh more ramped up
Paris uh I think was last year that they
came in in order to be able to crack
down on some of these these protests um
but uh civil rights groups felt that
they went too far uh and that actually
there was existing legislation that they
could have used but increasingly it
seems that uh people are feel that this
specific group targeting not just sports
events but of course we've seen them uh
you know do this logo go slows is that
what it's called
um you know marching down streets and
and sort of blocking traffic and so on
as well the ending station Rebellion
um uh I have really sort of got the
Public's backs up and
um so much so that I think one of the
original Founders
um of just stop oil and thunder is
indeed uh said a couple of weeks ago
that actually uh it was it was about
time that they that we thought their
tactics because if they ended up just uh
antagonizing the public rather than them
over to their arguments then actually
their points you know the point of their
protest was was questionable and surely
uh the one thing that they they want to
be doing is to win over the public so
that it exerts pressure on politicians
and if they're feeling to do that then I
think maybe some of these tactics need
to be Revisited and
um you know the fascinating thing is
we're looking at all these newspapers
that talk about this you know fuel uh
rip-off I think the Daily Mirror is
going on that the supermarket Scandal
about just stop oil protests at a time
when we've had June as as the confirmed
hottest June we've had since records
began and this sort of weirdness of
trying to get cheap fossil fuels at a
time when sea temperatures are raging
Harry does you know is the sort of as as
the eye gone off the boil was this Boris
Johnson's Baby and not Rishi sunax is
that is that what's happening in
government
26 here in the UK and you know some of
the environmental things that we saw
from the conservative government
sure but I mean we're living in a cost
of living crisis and you can ask us you
can ask any voter or any sun reader and
all the polls show that people
consistently put
um the cost of living crisis way ahead
in fact
um uh the poll we had last week you got
a poll of uh of the British electorate
where they had tackling the cost of
living crisis and reducing people's
prices at the tills at the pumps was was
a number one issue uh facing voters and
dealing with Net Zero was down at number
eight so I don't think anyone's taking
them off the ball but they're living in
reality if the fact is people are
struggling now and you know when you
start lecturing about what they you know
getting carbon neutral in in 30 years
time they look like you've come from
another planet so I think it's a
reflection on the fact that people
living there day to day lives are very
hard and it's almost impossible to
escape from that fact and you seem very
out of touch and I think the government
think they're onto something here with
the Justice oil thing with the with with
the pump watch fuel prices thing and
actually most people do not agree with
just up world most people want to see
the book thrown at them they want to see
them locked up and one of the biggest
problems that labor has is they are seen
to be on the side of these people
because you know they are the ones that
have consistently voted against all this
legislation and are taking money off of
just up to Old donors so you wonder
where there's a big old political fight
and you know labor looked like they're
on the way to number 10 but um I think
on this issue I think they're quite weak
yes and one wonders how long therefore
the cost of living and inflationary
pressures crisis continues and whether
it does have an impact on policy
proposals like you know ban on petrol
cars for example Pippa oh well that's
one of the things that's been under
discussion um whether the government
said this morning down the street said
this morning that there was not going to
be any reversal or withdrawal from that
from that pledge and I think the problem
that governments face or political
parties of all colors face is that while
the very acute in the moment cost of
living crisis obviously needs to be
dealt with and people need to be
supported through it and we all know the
factors that have led us to the position
successive governments haven't done
enough when it comes to preparing us for
for a carbon neutral future and you know
long-term planning Boris Johnson got
this actually but long-term planning is
absolutely key else we're going to end
up in the same position in five years 10
years 15 years time and energy prices
will increase as our own supplies
dwindle and fewer new licenses get
granted we won't be more dependent on
foreign states that produce oil like you
know parts of the Middle East and so on
and Russia if relations ever ever get
back to sort of some sort of normalized
position and actually in terms of
long-term energy security it's not just
about security aspect it's also about
having done prices and control ourselves
so investment by successive governments
over a long period of time up until this
point would have eased some of those
pressures we'd have our own renewable
regenerative energy here in the UK and
wouldn't have to be so reliant on others
so there is an argument that while of
course the cost of living crisis in the
Here and Now needs to be addressed we
also need to take the long-term Approach
at the same time and make sure that's
provision there in future for being more
self-reliant when it comes to energy
okay fascinating both of you thank you
very much indeed pepper Harry speak to
you in just a moment next though are
banks carrying out a chilling account
closures the day mail says they face an
investigation that animal after this
break
foreign
[Music]
came out in 2007 just on the eve of the
smartphone so of course it led to a
drastic opening up of of gambling and
online is where the majority of the harm
is that we're seeing in the clinics so
the ease of access the ubiquitous
advertising the way in which it has
embedded itself particularly into sports
and our national sports has led to
significant problems and as a result we
have hundreds of gambling related
suicides every year many of whom are
young men
if we're going to get serious about this
we do need to focus on
um restricting the exposure to children
and the softening of attitudes as
children get into adolescence and Beyond
they're unaware of the risks that
they're entering into
so we do need to restrict advertising um
it's been done across Europe now there
are many countries well ahead of us
um so advertising particularly when
children are exposed during the day and
into the evening would be a start to
this but we also need to address the
problem of where individuals open
accounts and then the industry are
trying to move them over with aggressive
marketing to the online casino gambling
and that's where the highest addiction
rates and harm is so there's a number of
issues that the government haven't quite
grappled with yet that we're calling for
significantly better reforms around that
your viewers will be well aware of how
ubiquitously gambling advertising is
across our screens and the radio the
majority of which is online and targeted
to people so again once you've opened
the account you're going to get a
significant increase in marketing as
well and it's those people who have the
most problems that are getting the most
marketing now on the issue of sports
sponsorship we've got the introduction
of this voluntary ban on Sports on
Football Premier League football shirts
research is about to show that only
seven percent of gambling logos are
going to be addressed by this voluntary
uh ban so these are the kinds of issues
where reforms are just not going far
enough to reduce the harm and get to
grips with the level of suicides that
we're experiencing people who are coming
to us are metaphorically on their knees
they're suicidal they may have lost
relationships they may have lost their
homes and we need to do much more to
prevent the harm in the first place
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview with me once again pipakura
political editor of the guardian and
Harry Cole political editor of the sun
welcome back to both of you and people
are going to get your story in the
guardian if that's okay
um and there has been a great deal of
concern about firstly the cost of
nurseries and therefore how ratios of
care are changing and so what's the plan
that you've heard about from labor that
you've reported on here
well labor has decided that uh naught to
three age group is absolutely critical I
say labor has decided this has long been
accepted by Leading experts in the in
the sector and of course the sector
itself that focusing on not to threes
absolutely critical if you're going to
try and create a Level Playing Field
when children start primary school and I
interviewed Bridget Phillips in the
shadow education secretary who said even
when she went to visit primary and
secretary schools head teachers would
say to if you if you if Libra win the
next election and end up in government
you end up running the DFE if you have
any money please focus it and not to
threes because that is the single best
way of trying to sort of create
opportunity and and eradicate inequality
and it's long proven people like Andrew
LED some of the Tory side as well as
obviously historically Tessa Jail who's
behind setting up labor sure start
centers have always agreed that this is
this is a priority so labor is basically
saying that this is going to be priority
and in terms of doing this and the story
that we've got on the front page of the
Guardian uh tomorrow is that they're
going to consider they're going to look
at putting in uh graduate educated so um
degree level teachers in nurseries of
course lots of stuff in the nurseries
cut in nurseries particularly private
ones and voluntary sexual ones are
currently
um uh not degree level educated they're
Nursery nurses and so on so it's about
raising quality across the board in the
nurseries that exist they're also going
to look at opening up more Nursery
places and Primary School settings
there's about I think it's about 1600
1700 primary schools across England and
only so it's 1300 primary schools across
England don't have earlier settings on
sites and another 400 do currently have
state maintained nurseries and labor are
going to look at expanding that so
formally linking early years and child
care in with the education system to
sort of like create a situation where
that remains a focus regardless who ends
up being in government in the future yes
and certainly reception teachers have
often complained that children they get
you know often can't hold a pen or
sometimes cut and hold a pen or even
can't even go to the toilet on their own
sometimes as well so it is a big area
let's move on to the Metro shall we and
uh the story that um she who judged rule
breaking broke the rules
um uh tell us about that Harry
yeah well sort of
um I mean this is the sort of
long-running But ultimately
um slightly damp squibby investigation
by the cabinet office that um Sue gray
managed a slightly Water Hole by having
absolutely nothing to do with it
um so this was the the cabin obviously
the skin distressor was a civil
service-led investigation into the
former sort of Whitehall enforcer who
was actually not right at the center of
things right when she left but still
pretty closely involved at the very top
basically said look she she you know
evidence suggests that she contacted
kirst armor and oh sorry I contacted her
in October of last year she continued to
work for the civil service for four
months and therefore the rules were
broken because you didn't declare that
contact but they're sort of it's been
sort of lawyered to death the sort of
statement and so they inserted premium
fascia which basically means look we've
had a look at about it we can't prove it
either way you know this hasn't been
tested in any court or won't ever be but
it looks awesome will actually break the
rules and label quite right rightly
frankly have gone yeah booze Booyah to
that uh let's move on she starts in
September six month cooling period but
you know there is a lot of anger not
just on the ministerial side on official
side as well lots of civil servants
think that sugay's behavior did bring
the
um the notion of civil service
impartiality into dispute uh whether she
was you know whether she was be doing
anything wrong or briefing stamina
behind the backs or any any of that the
appearance of neutrality is as important
as the neutrality itself so lots of sore
sort of Saw wounds there the amusing
thing I think though is that the way the
polls are going if Sue gray though
carries on working for labor Beyond past
the general election when the point
she's been hired for she can be back uh
probably in Whitehall where she left off
with lots of people who are quite grumpy
with us still the Tories might be gone
but there'll be a lot of senior civil
servants who should have to work with
again who um frankly are spitting tax
okay um less than a minute left on the
last three daily mail uh Pippa at the
Nigel farage Bank Route with further
implications the paper says
yeah well this is a suggestion that I
mean Nigel farage obviously uh uh was
complaining the other day about his bank
account being shut down without warning
since then we've had a series of
campaign groups individuals saying that
similar had happened to them and it's
become a bit of a political storm
because it's not so you know I think the
loss of your viewers as well or some of
your viewers may have been in a in a
position
um a similar position and Flora farage
is saying is that uh his account's been
closed because they don't like his views
on controversial topics the treasury uh
Andrew Griffiths the city Minister has
suggested that um it is good to look
into the allegations that uh overzealous
lenders are blocking clients without
good reason
um very story and peace have complained
Anthony Bryan who I think ran the
British Bankers Association I hope I've
got that that right
um I'm rushing you apologies we're
running out of time there I'm gonna have
to call a halt if you don't mind paper
career Harry Cole thank you very much
indeed we'll see you more obviously in
the 11 for now thank you to the weather
now